[موسيقى]
كل مدينة لها شخصية
قادمة من جدة ، وأعتقد بصدق
أننا المنطقة الأكثر إبداعًا في
المملكة العربية السعودية.
الرياض لديها طرق عيش خاصة بها ،
فهي أكثر سرعة ، فهي أكثر
جدية من خلال الزبدة ، ثم
لديك Jitter ،
نود أن نشعر بالأشياء التي نحب أن نأخذها في
وقتنا ، Jitter هي مدينة باردة للغاية ، لقد
كنا دائمًا رواة القصص ، وهي
دائمًا هويتنا كمدينة ،
اسمي أيمن إدريس تامانو ، لقد كنت صانع
أفلام لأكثر من 15  سنوات بين الحين والآخر ،
أقوم ببعض التصوير الفوتوغرافي
قليلاً من الموسيقى
[الموسيقى] التي
ولدت وترعرعت في جدة ،
يجد صانع الأفلام الحائز على جوائز
نفسه دائمًا منجذبًا إلى أقدم جزء من المدينة
إذا كنت أرغب في الحصول على الإلهام ، فأنا أذهب إلى صالح
وما عليك سوى التجول والتوقف
وإجراء محادثة مع شخص غريب ،
فهذه منسوجات ممتعة للغاية هنا
نشأ هؤلاء الأشخاص في برلين
وبقوا هناك طوال حياتهم
حتى لغتهم تعرف الطريقة التي
يتحدثون بها باللغة التي
يستخدمونها  إنها عربية كلاسيكية ،
لذا فهي تتمتع بقوة كبيرة ولديها
طريقة قوية جدًا للرسم بالكلمات في
بعض الأحيان قد تثير
شيئًا فيك فكرة فقط من هذا
التفاعل الصغير ،
الناس ودودون للغاية ، خاصةً
هنا في جدة ، مرحباً كيف حالكم يا رفاق
هل يمكنني التقاط صورة ،
حسنًا ، حسنًا ، حسنًا ، واحد اثنان
وثلاثة
كان دائمًا موطنًا للعديد من
الفنانين ،
هذا هو المكان الذي ستجد فيه مكانًا
يمكنك فيه الازدهار وصقل
المهارات اللازمة التي تحتاجها لإتقان
حرفتك
من المحتمل أن يأتي هنا مرة واحدة في العام مثلي أو مجموعة
من المصورين
ويفعلون نوعًا ما مثل تبادل
لإطلاق النار ومقارنة الصور ، فقد
أصبح ميدان تدريب
للمصورين ليكونوا صادقين ، فقد
استوحى الكثير من هؤلاء الفنانين من
جذور  الحجاز وبطريقة ما
يمكنك تتبعه مرة أخرى إلى هذه النوافذ التي
يطلقون عليها اسم التجفيف
الذي يترجم إلى Windows ،
إنهم
شعب حجازي جميل هم سكان
المنطقة الغربية من مكة
وصولاً إلى جدة
اعتاد والدي التقاط صور لهم
على  فيلم وبالنسبة له كان بالفعل
شيئًا تاريخيًا وكان ذلك في
السبعينيات ، وأعتقد ، نعم ، أتذكر عندما
حصلت على أول كاميرا لي ، كان أول
شيء فعلته هو المجيء إلى هنا والتقاط
الصور
كان دائمًا مكانًا نشعر فيه
بالراحة  بالتعبير عن إبداعنا
ومن الجيد جدًا أن نرى أنه
ينمو بالفعل ليصبح شيئًا
رسميًا أكثر ، كما هو منظم الآن ، فقد
أقيم مهرجان البحر الأحمر السينمائي على سبيل المثال لأول مرة في
لديك ، حيث
أقيم أيضًا في
[الموسيقى]
حيث  حدث مهرجان موسيقي كبير
في ألبرت كما تعلم ولم يكن
مجرد مرحلة واحدة ، بل كانت هناك خمس
مراحل منتشرة في جميع أنحاء القمة